now, let's look at
the bz and Theorem again because this time we
are going to use
the
formula the actual formula for
or to arrive at that quantity.
They will look at before that 28%
the Bayesian
theorem
the formula for it rather
can we express different ways algebraically?
Which is why we want to look at at least two approaches.
The first one will actually use this form of
the Bayesian theorem.
The other one will use What's called the odds
and likelihood ratios.
and the book
to which I was referring.
Use it this uses the second approach.
So even though this exercise is from the book. I will first show
you my
adaptation of that example
using the this very well known formula.
And in the second approach we'll look at the approach that the book
takes.
Although the book doesn't actually use much mathematical notation.
I'm going to write it out for you. Just so that you know that.
There are different ways we can arrive at that same number algebraically.
Now what I have done here is I've
replaced A and B with
age sub G and T sub P respectively. So
H is hypothesis the guilty hypothesis.
And T is test positive test. So the
question was what is the probability?
of the athlete being guilty
given
their test result was positive
So the probability of being guilty given a positive test.
We want to find out.
the marginal
and Joint probabilities
and then plug in the values.
So this is the first approach.
So now let's go ahead and see how we can calculate the marginal and
Joint probabilities for
this formula
and let me pull up the figure just
so we can.
Let me pull up that figure so we can see where we are getting.
these numbers from
now we start by finding out how many
tests were positive.
And how many tests were negative?
And then so we find a modular probabilities first because the
information is right here.
And then we can figure out the joint probabilities.
just to make it clear where I got these numbers from
let me at the fraction.
There we go.
now
How do we know how many?
How do we know the probability of testing positive? Well, we
have it here right 68 athletes tested positive
and that's 68 over 1000.
So 1,000
Is the number of athletes who both tested
positive and who tested negative?
So 68 over 68 plus 932 or
we can just say 68 over 1,000.
So we get about seven percent about seven percent.
of athletes tested positively
At 93 almost 93% of
athletes tested negative again.
We take 932 divided by 1,000.
and of course these two probabilities
add up to one.
Now, let's see how we can acquire these joint probabilities.
again with the first column
We want to go to the athletes who tested positive
really positively and we want to see.
What is the probability of that athlete having
been guilty?
So that's just
19 over 1,000
19 athletes tested positively
and they were actually doping so that's 19 over
1,000.
and 49 athletes
Tested positively.
But they were innocent.
That's the second hypothesis here.
so the probability of testing positive
and being innocent
Is 49 over 1000?
Because they tested positively right they tested positively.
But they are actually innocent.
So the probability of
testing positively
and
being innocent all over the total number of possible outcomes.
All over the total number of possible outcomes.
So keep this in mind that 1,000 remember?
Is the total number of possible outcomes?
And then while we don't need the negative
column.
For approach number one, it's good
to have this in here. It's good to have this here for reference.
So if you look at the negative.
branch
931 are innocent
and they tested negatively. So that's 931 over
1000.
one athlete tested positively
Excuse me, one athlete was guilty.
When they even though they tested negatively.
Okay.
and of course if we add up these if we had a
if we add a diffractions in this row.
We get this sum and again this these two sums
add up to one.
So this is you always want to check.
the sum to make sure
And that's how you make sure the values are correct?
With this table we can now calculate.
the relevant
marginal and joint problem probabilities. I say relevant because
we're not really concerned with the second column.
Not just yet.
So we just want to know what is the probability of testing positively what is
a probability of being guilty?
And what is the probability of testing positively?
And being guilty and we have that information up here in the
table.
Now we can use these values to plug them into our
formula.
So again, this is the Bayesian.
theorem
this is what the Bayesian theorem tells us.
now over here we have the product of
the conditional probability
and the marginal probability or
they are also known as the likelihood.
and the odds
Now we don't have this conditional probability now table.
But we do know that this expression is
equivalent to that expression.
If you need to remember this you can watch the
previous videos.
So we can express this.
Product as the joint probability of testing positively and guilty,
but we have that value.
Right there.
And we also have the value for the marginal probability for testing positively.
So all we need to do then is just plug in these numbers.
Which gives us this fraction?
Evaluating we get 28%
This is the algebraic way of solving.
this particular problem
now in practice you might have to
spend some time.
Drawing out this table drawing out
the tree.
Going over this table, like it will be very helpful.
If you actually plug in these values because there's a
lot going on.
and you can
lose track
of what you're doing.
And in fact, I did I had to go over this a few times to make sure.
that the table
of marginal and Joint probabilities is a correct
reflection of the tree.
So when you're doing something like this expect yourself to
spend some time.
to help properly collect all the information